I'm Zack Miko and I am the first broad
model for IMG Models yeah I was big all
growing up I actually I think still have
nightmares about being dragged to the
Husky section when I was a kid I don't
know what for all big guys that's a word
that will mean something different for
the rest of our lives when I was growing
up I felt like I didn't belong because
of my size he learned to compensate in
other ways I tried to be funny I learned
to play the guitar you kind of find
other reasons for people to like you
other than the way you look I'm an actor
and one day my acting manager was
talking to her friend who is actually a
makeup artist we worked in a studio and
I said they were looking for a
plus-sized guy and they couldn't find
one and I got a text message from my
manager saying how big is your waist and
I was like well why why would you want
to know that and then I told her and
then I was in it for a test shoot an
hour later and then later that week I
had my first gig and it was fun it was
great I enjoyed it I got a lot of press
for for being on the target website it
was the first time my body type had been
shown not just by them but by a
mainstream retailer so a lot of people
got very excited I started talking and I
was very lucky that Ivan Bart the head
of IMG Models actually found me on
Instagram and sent me a message couple
days later I was in the office with not
just Ivan but the head of the men's and
women's fashion board and different
managers and PR and I was like this is
incredible I guess this is for real and
I still was very overwhelmed by it until
Ivan started talking about diversity and
inclusion and evolution and his dreams
for not only IMG Models but for the
whole fashion world it hit me right in
the heart and I knew that it wasn't fake
it wasn't just that it was like this is
a real movement that we're trying to do
fashion world brawn is the new
distinction for big and tall men it's
all about taking the positive aspects of
what being big and tall is and
highlighting that the same way the
women's division is curved before this
you kind of find pieces you really like
and then you wear them a lot because you
know they fit I mean you see your
typical male models and everyone has a
washboard stomach and a perfect v-shape
you grew up thinking that's the only
thing that it actually can be and I
learned to love myself and my body
through modeling and I'm really hoping
to do the same for others I think my
main message as a model is that I can
get even a couple people to feel good
about the way they look not what they
think other people want them to be but
how you look right now is beautiful is
attractive and is is valid because I
know that's a feeling that I didn't have
for a long time
you